[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you
eating ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony them
[Music]
thank you
scary lake is scared of a song so is
Marjorie Taylor green and all the other
real America First Nazi bigots
kind of seems kind of weird that the uh
ones who want to cancel who are so
concerned about cancer culture want to
cancel a song it always seems kind of
strange to me but it's not about the
song
really not even about who sang it
spot the sentiment of the song I mean if
you went and read the words
to the black national anthem lift every
voice and sing is the song
titled
this morning I was wondering why
a bunch of white nationalists were
terrified
of something being called and sung at
the NFL Super Bowl as the black national
anthem I was wondering to myself why are
they so
freaking terrified of a song
why I really I really I realized why
when you read the lyrics and we're going
to talk about it here in the first 30
minutes I honestly believed that today I
was gonna come on I I predicted
yesterday on the Sunday rant on patreon
only for you patreon members out there I
posted a video and I believe that today
I was going to be talking about Eminem
commercials
and Rihanna in the first 30 minutes I
was wrong
that's right folks I can admit it when
I'm wrong I was wrong it's much worse
than that way way worse
than that
two things
one on Super Bowl commercials and one on
the white nationalist real America First
Nazi parties racism
first and then let's get the commercial
thing out of the way you've seen all the
weird Jesus commercials
um just as a sidebar the people who paid
for those commercials helped pay and
support and write the law that
overturned Roe v Wade in Dobbs in in the
Dobbs case that's right
that's right same
want you to believe that we're not
enemies uh we're not enemies don't treat
us as enemies Jesus told you to love his
enemies that's what they want you to
believe
so just as a sidebar we'll we'll leave
that there and maybe we'll talk about it
later on in the show how the group
behind the weird ass Jesus commercials
are trying to Gaslight Americans
same paid to write
legislation
millions of dollars to overturn Roe v
Wade to strip away human rights away
from women
to their bodily autonomy hmm
seems kind of weird that it's the same
people who are really upset and really
offended by a song that might or might
not be referred to as the black national
anthem so much so that they won't even
stand for it I'm surprised Carrie Lake
didn't get on a knee to be quite honest
I mean isn't that the same
that were so are so offended by this
song
that boycotted the NFL in the first
place because Colin Kaepernick took a
knee because police officers around the
country were murdering black men
without consequence
without repercussion it's almost like
they were being allowed to slaughter
black men hmm
and he was silently speaking out by
taking a knee
and they were gonna boycott you remember
this they were burning their
jerseys and the NFL they're awoke
and all this
you'll remember this they still talk
about it they still Yammer on about how
Colin Kaepernick ruined the NFL because
he took a knee doesn't even
play in the NFL
because he's black
the first Super Bowl where two black men
are the quarterbacks on either team
they decide in the pregame show
to have Chris Stapleton sing the
national anthem great version by the way
foreign
but they also
decided
that they would sing lift every voice
and sing now let me give you a little
history on this song so I can
set the record straight Marjorie Taylor
green you talk I I I don't
know if Chris Stapleton knows this yet
or not
but Chris Stapleton is being invoked by
Marjorie Taylor Green in her little
white supremacy trudge on social media
today as if the white dude singing a
song was much better than the black
woman just because he's white
let me tell you something Marjorie
Taylor green and Chris Stapleton I hope
speaks up on this I really hope he does
let me tell you something Marjorie
Taylor green Chris Stapleton in 2020 in
an interview with CBS This Morning said
unequivocally and said he does not
regret the statements either that black
lives absolutely matter
Chris Stapleton is woke
as you can get with a white dude with a
beard I mean maybe I'm maybe I'm a
little more woke than Chris Stapleton I
don't know maybe we should have a woke
off me and Chris
it's not complicated to
understand history in this country and
know what the was done to people
that are our citizens that don't want
revenge and if you listen to the words
of lift every voice and sing the black
national anthem you would know that's
what the it's about go read them
you bigots go read the
lyrics it invokes God
it invokes faith it invokes christian
religion
you stupid bastards
all the while they're running
commercials telling us oh don't hate us
because we're fascist and we want to we
want to take away people's rights and
Liberty and we want to definitely Smash
Up equality and equity in the name of
Jesus but don't hate us for that
out of here with that nonsense
I hope Chris Stapleton speaks up I I
liked his version of the national anthem
Chris Stapleton is a great artist I
appreciate that he also understands
American history and understands that
the America that he was told he grew up
in is not the America he grew up in the
same as me same as me
we were told lies
and we shouldn't be telling people lies
in this country anymore about the
history of this country we just should
not let me tell you a little
history and facts here
live every voice and sing was written in
1900 as a poem
it was put to the lyrics were put to
sound in 1905. you got it 1900 1905 the
turn of the century
Woodrow Wilson wrote an executive order
in 1916. you follow me
16 years after lift every voice and sing
was written and known as the black
national anthem it was only then in 1916
when President Wilson
signed an executive order making the
Star-Spangled Banner the national anthem
you idiots believe that the
national anthem George Washington made
the Star-Spangled Banner the national
anthem or some they referred they
had several songs that were referred to
as an national anthem long before 1916
and they weren't the Star-Spangled
Banner
it wasn't in it it wasn't until 1931
that it was put into law by Herbert
Hoover
you want some history on the
goddamn songs that were sung
the history is this
and and I I read a tweet this morning
and it rang true I retweeted it's got
the n-word in it so if you're offended
by the n-word you definitely do not want
to go read it but I don't give a
it's exactly what they mean by make
America great great again exactly what
they mean by woke
you you you white
nationalists real America First Nazis
out there
I'm talking to you you trumped up
right now I hope you're on
here and I hope you're listening
you have stolen every single piece and
appropriated every single piece of black
culture and acting like it's
White Rock and Roll rap dance
food every bit of your culture
is Black Culture you dumb
you have no idea what country you're
living in and you have been deluded
and mind into believing that
somehow some way
that this country has the culture it has
only because of white men
Marjorie Taylor green you
scumbag you scumbag
and again I hope Chris Stapleton
I hope Chris Stapleton responds
with her with him and her mouth
yeah
he might not who knows
but as far as far as Marjorie Taylor
green or Kerry lake or Donald Trump
Iran desantos whichever one of these
scumbag these these real
America First Nazis
out there
that want to act like the only song that
mattered the only song that rang true to
the American people was somehow the
white dude singing the national anthem
am I offended
that Chris Stapleton sung the National
absolutely not
not offended at all
matter of fact there there's no better
woke white man
who believes that black lives absolutely
matter and has no regrets for his
statements as such in 2020
should be singing that song
let's go look at the history look at the
lyrics
and you understand that you're
lucky
you're lucky that black folks in
this country do not want revenge they
love this country more than anything
they definitely love this country way
more than white nationalists
their entire culture was appropriated to
build this country they built this
country with their backs on slave labor
not to mention built the backs of slave
labor on Stolen land from indigenous
people
and Kerry Lake
and Marjorie Taylor green and all these
trumped up white nationalists are
terrified
that there's a song referred to as the
black national anthem oh my God it was
sung at the Super Bowl where the
majority of players are black we're both
quarterbacks on on the days were black
it was done in February during Black
History Month
foreign
you ass
you're always talking about how the left
can't handle this and the left can't
handle it get the out of here with
that nonsense
not even to mention Rihanna
with the pure intention of not showing
any skin from the neck down did you
catch that that's I mean I don't know if
that was the stylist or what the point
was
but it seemed to me
to me my read on it was let's see how
crazy these Kooks can get
if I don't show a single bit of skin
from the neck down
did you catch that
I mean everyone caught that Rihanna
looked looked like she may be pregnant I
don't even want to go there
I'm not even I'm not even gonna touch
that with a 10-foot pole but that was
the the hubbub
she carried the entire halftime show on
her own
the floating levels and the it was
something I've never seen in a halftime
show
something I'd never seen in a halftime
but because Rihanna is outspoken against
Trump because he's a racist what
don't you people understand the reason
why black people are pissed off
at you white nationalists is because
you're bigots
you are racist
you hate black people and you hide
behind your Bible and your Christianity
to do it and you use words like thug and
woke
as a dog whistle for the n-word it's
true
you try you try in states to erase an
entire entire part of our history
to make sure that even as an elective a
college prep course elective Ronda
Santos doesn't even want
African-American students in Florida
taking an elective about their own
history as a college prep course because
he's scared they may know the truth
and that's why they're mad about this
song
that's why they're pissed off about this
it tells the truth
and they lay it bare they they again you
you think the quiet part out loud but
they're well beyond the quiet Port part
or out loud
well beyond it
because their projection
of Colin Kaepernick kneeling during the
national anthem
that he was disrespecting our troops
their projection
because it's pure projection every
single time
now they're disdain
for a song
that describes
the patriotism
of of emancipated slaves
and how they love their country because
of faith of God if you just go read the
lyrics to the song
they disrespected on purpose by sitting
and not standing
acting as if the white man singing was
much better than the black woman oh way
better
projection
is always on with these people
every single time I mean again these are
the same that are tweeting
about it oh my God I watch Superbowl and
oh my God I can't believe it
they had a black woman singing a black
man whatever that is
before they had the white man who with
it who looks who looks like a bigot who
sounds like a bigot he's not
singing the accident and national anthem
and we need to get rid of wokism
no no we need to get rid of racism
we need to get rid of bigotry
we want you fascist to crawl back
underneath your rock
that's what the we want that's what
the we need in this country
now for this
not for this
lift every voice and sing
till Earth and Heaven ring
ring with the harmonies
of Liberty
it's the first three lines of that song
let me repeat them again
lift every voice and sing
tell Earth and Heaven ring
ring with the harmonies
of Liberty
this is a song
that they're offended by
the reason why they're offended by it I
I tell you time and time and time and
time again they hate democracy
democracy is their enemy
democracy means they cannot tell you
what the to be who you can love how
you identify what religion you are or
you aren't where you live
what you can and cannot say what you can
and cannot sing at the Super
Bowl
these are all threats to their
oppression on people of color in this
country from White Christian
nationalists
and it's clear because they love the
Jesus commercials
oh they love the Jesus commercials from
the people who Stripped Away human
rights from women in this country to
their bodily autonomy oh they
love that oh yeah
look we're gonna be your enemies we're
gonna be your enemies and we're gonna
wanna appropriate your culture take your
entire history and stuff it away in a
box as if it's our history White
History not black history
and we're gonna try to get rid of your
rights and we're gonna press the
out of you to the point where we would
want to kill you
that's the freedom they want
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty
not Liberty Lift Every voice and sing
till Earth and Heaven ring ring with the
harmonies of Liberty
1900.
1900 that song is written
John Roseman Johnson
who died 1954.
compose the music his brother James
Weldon Johnson
wrote the lyrics
in 1900.
let me repeat it I I know I keep
repeating these lyrics but oh my God
lift every voice and sing to Earth and
Heaven ring ring with the harmonies of
Liberty
I tell you all the time what we strive
for
is Liberty Liberty will deliver Equity
inequality
the Johnson Brothers knew it in the turn
of the century
not nearly 30 years after the Civil War
after the emancipation of slaves
they knew Liberty would deliver them
equity and equality and it was a long
hard bloody Road they knew it
but they believed in it they believed in
our country
they believed in the 14th Amendment
the new America
and you should too
that's why it's worth fighting for every
single inch every single
centimeter that we have to fight
for our democracy and democracy around
the world for that matter
whether it be Brazil or Ukraine
we must be loud and proud
of our Liberty
and seeking the Liberty through our
freedoms and our rights that the
constitution grants us
to get to the best equity and equality
that we possibly can
maybe not our lifetimes but maybe our
children maybe our grandchildren's
lifetime
it's not perfect
it's not easy it's definitely not easy
look democracy is not for the
authoritarian week
like white Christian nationalists like
the real America First Nazi party
democracy is not for those folks they're
weak
they're ass
they can't handle truth they can't
handle history
they can't handle their privilege being
being equitable
they can't handle it and they
won't and that's why they're fighting so
hard
to destroy
our democracy
and at the local levels at school boards
the state levels like Ron DeSanto
setting up a fascist state in Florida
and Missouri Texas Kansas all the other
states following suit
trying to out fascist Florida and Ron
desantos
or our federal government
in the House of Representatives
where they continue the trudge of lies
and projection
in the Committees of Jim Jordan's
weaponization of government
and the Twitter files
and nationally on the campaign stage
as Donald Trump will Ascend to the
denomination folks he's going to
Donald Trump will be their
nominee this morning on Morning Joe
I heard Joseph Joe Scarborough come on
the show man I'll give you two
I'll tell you what you're going to be
talking about two months from now okay
two months from now I'll tell you what
you're going to be talking about
man
this morning Joe Scarborough was talking
about how Ron DeSantis can't handle
Donald Trump oh who's been saying that
who's been saying that out loud for the
last two months
Joe just if you want to give me a ring
or send me an email I'll tell you what
you're going to be talking about on
Morning Joe in the next two months
doubt me doubt me just
doubt me
this morning
thank you
I was wrong again I was wrong about what
I was going to talk about this morning I
really figured
we were going to be talking about the
Rihanna halftime show and Eminem's woke
woke woke candy commercial
I was dead wrong I was dead wrong I'm
almost glad I'm wrong
I'm almost glad I'm wrong they're
showing they're showing who they are
all we have to do is amplify what
they're saying so the entire country
hears them because folks your friends
your family they have no idea they have
no idea that these bigots are
acting like that song Lift Every voice
and sing what's the worst thing that's
ever happened to America ever and it's
the wokest thing whatever the that
mean well I know what it means black
woke means black
to what it means you're racist
they're bigots of course they are
but again we're going to stay ahead of
the curve here on the Tony Michaels
podcast that way Joe Scarborough can
watch today's episode in six weeks from
now he can go ahead and do it on his on
his show
on Morning Joe
ah Joe Scarborough
you're behind man you're behind dude I
mean yeah you gotta you got an all right
show it's all right
Mika's the best part of the show to be
quite honest with you when I listen to
it every so often Mika's the best part
of the show
uh but Joe you're behind man
this whole DeSantis is is not going to
be able to handle Trump as someone's
been saying that for quite some time now
and it's been a predict prediction for a
while maybe you should give credit for
it I don't know I might I might go on
Morning Joe to explain why they're
stealing my content but here's
here's what I'll tell you I probably
couldn't get on there because of my
mouth
oh they hate my mouth
oh yeah yeah they hate my mouth
they ABS I I don't know how many times
I've been told man you really could have
like a national show like it could be
syndicated if you just stop saying the f
word like what the
can you imagine can you imagine the Tony
Michaels podcast without the f word
because I tried I really did I tried I
was like maybe I no I can't
I can't I won't
them this is for you
this is for you
I'm not gonna stop saying it for them
because this is for you every single
weekday noon Eastern 11 Central 9
Pacific on YouTube Twitter and twitch
free
you don't need a subscription to listen
to this show you just gotta have a cell
phone or TV or something
or you can also download every single
episode on Apple Spotify and Google all
two hours make sure to go subscribe to
the YouTube channel though you're going
to want to do that go subscribe to
YouTube channel and I want to thank
everyone uh that has joined patreon I
did not expect this many members we are
on the road to 100. I know it doesn't
sound like a lot 100 but to me it's a
lot
it really is a lot of support and it
means the world to me because you are
the best audience so go to the Tony
michaels.com if you want to check out
the patreon page and the extra content
that you would get but I will never
never gate this show this two-hour show
which we're hoping to get the three
hours and the more support we get on
patreon the quicker we'll get there to a
free three hour show every single
weekday absolutely free for your viewing
and your pleasure peppered with the f
word everyone stick around we'll be
right back right after this
break
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product part in blanket I've got
you covered pardon blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup pardon blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardons not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
oh apparently over on Twitch they're
confused about me
you're confused over on Twitch
what the hell is this white guy with a
beard sounds like a hillbilly
oh man he's saying he's woke
seems liberal as
you know they they're saying only one
guy over there is confused I don't know
yeah
it is kind of confusing I have to admit
um that
you see a guy like me or Chris Stapleton
and and know that we're quote woke
again I just believe in equity and
equality for all
and I I actually go a step further and I
believe that I as a white man who has
white privilege definite white male
privilege in this country should use my
privilege to smash that privilege up
into little bitty pieces that's
what I believe
that's what I think that's what I think
I was put here to do
with this microphone
may not seem like a lot
but I believe this microphone gives me
the ability
to do that and that is what I'm going to
continue to do whether you like it or
not
and that is why I will probably never
leave oh here's here's Dustin
he's he's projecting for Dustin on
Facebook look he thinks I won't call him
out what a beta
Dustin let me tell you something it is
really weak and feeble to believe
anything one person tells you like a fat
slob down at Mar-A-Lago
a laptop having documents
stealing treasonous piece of okay I
don't know if you guys heard I don't
know if you heard this Dustin but the
laptop from hell is real
the laptop from hell is real
everybody
why do you think Donald Trump was saying
that why do you think he was typing it
out in tweets he knew he had a live tap
with top secret documents illegally he
knew it he knew there was an actual
laptop from hell at his house
in his golf course in his possession
the thing is scarier than that is the
thumb drive they found Dustin did you
know that they found a thumb
drive I almost bet Dustin that you're a
conspiracy theorist
dollars to donuts and I bet you're
dumber than dog too Dustin oh buddy
I bet you're dumber than a dog
turd
so let me give you a little conspiracy
theory here Dustin what do you think
if a thumb drive worked its way
into Jared kushner's pocket huh what do
you think about that a a president's
son-in-law you know
what about that and he would go overseas
oh that seems to Qatar oh man where he
would go saddle up with his Saudi
business partners maybe trade trade a
thumb drive or maybe plug a thumb drive
into another laptop from hell that the
Saudis had to copy files somewhere maybe
for money who knows maybe for favors who
knows Dustin I mean you're a conspiracy
theorist I'm almost damn sure of it
almost damn sure of it
the Dustin leave and that poor said
piece of
oh Justin
he's he's mad he's mad because I made a
couple videos about the drive-through
and I won't I won't oh
seeing this is the other one you know
you're gonna eat these words no
dude I've never ate my words yet
not yet
you you should been listening for a long
time you dumb
you should have been listening and you
should come back and keep listening
you learn a thing or two
yeah and by the way Dustin
Alphas don't have to call themselves
alvas and Alphas definitely don't call
other people betas
just because they want equity and
equality for all people you racist piece
of that's right I'm calling you out
you're racist if you call me a
beta because I'm like hey we want equity
and equality and Liberty in this country
I don't know democracy
you're a bigot so good luck to
you Dustin and good luck to all the
people that will oh yeah I watched every
day that's great man you're really
pumping my algorithm I
appreciate it keep commenting keep
being here every single invite
all your trashy ass friends too
invite them invite them Dustin all your
little your little snowflake
friends get them in here to comment too
you little you ass
just like your Jesus Trump okay
let's move on
okay uh oh yes oh yes oh yes the lamp
top from hell
yeah oh my God can you believe this
stuff can you believe
can you believe
I just can't believe it it is oh my God
such big news
that Donald Trump had a laptop from hell
that he's been projecting this whole
time not only that he has a thumb drive
from Hell apparently too it's a demonic
thumb drive uh not only that and we find
out uh also over the weekend and I think
this is a key uh point in evidence for
Jack Smith's case against Donald Trump
and against his allies in the scheme for
the Cheeto dust kangaroo coup on January
6.
so here here's what I'll tell you
about the piece of news that we found
out Donald Trump hired a private firm
to investigate voter fraud
when that firm came back from the money
that they paid them well maybe promised
them maybe not paid them we don't know
that much
the investigation that they did in the
voter fraud that private firm that they
sought out and they had do an
investigation
found that it wasn't stolen there was no
election fraud
there wasn't anything weird about the
election and that Donald Trump has had
lost
which means folks that there is evidence
evidence
that Donald Trump knew
that he had lost and the big lie was a
big lie
knew it
the entire time
which I think is key evidence in Jack
Smith's case against Donald Trump for
January 6 and also the documents case
I don't know if you're following a
bouncing ball here
but uh I've said from the beginning that
Donald Trump
stole our documents from our government
for a couple different reasons the first
reason is to cover up his coup attempt
because it was not successful they did
not successfully carry out the Cheeto
dust kangaroo for him to be dictator and
King
and molester of our country and our
constitution
the other reason why I think he stole
documents is to sell them
and to trade them why do you think it's
on a laptop and a thumb drive
how in the how in the are you going
how in the are you going to trade
away documents without it being digital
I mean I guess you can carry the secret
documents in the suitcase and
and carry them to uh to to the to the
World Cup
Jared Kushner can fold them up and put
them in his pocket maybe hand a few to
Elon to put in his back mom jeans pocket
that way they could you know do the
transaction with Saudis but what easier
way than to have them on a thumb
drive
I'm not saying that happened I'm not I'm
not alleging that happened I'm just
saying it feels like to me that if if a
person I mean if someone told me hey you
got to get these documents that you're
not supposed to have
from one country to another and you're
gonna pass them off during like a sports
ball event
they're gonna have like a laptop that
they can download them on within a
couple minutes
you know while you're acting like you're
watching the game
eating some food enjoying the sports
ball thing the sports ball event
I would be like well the easiest way to
do this to do this crime the easiest way
to commit this crime is to put these
documents
on a thumb drive
and just just carry it in your pocket
that'd be the easiest way
I mean who's got I mean hell you can
make the thumb drive look like anything
dude make it look like a thing of
chapstick
foreign
port or you get on a private
charter jet you don't have to hmm
what's that there's something to this
just saying I don't like to spend
conspiracy theories here
but I want to know why our top
secret documents were on a goddamn thumb
drive
because the laptop from hell
is um is a great projection from the
Cheeto dust q and honor oh
we didn't see that coming we didn't see
any of this coming
but the fact I don't know if you
remember this
um the laptop talk and the laptop Saga
but uh Matt Getz at one point in a
hearing in the house when uh in this 117
Congress when Democrats were in charge
uh Jerry Nadler was the chair and Matt
gatz raised his hand he said hey I want
to put this thumb drive that's got 100
bytes laptop into evidence
into official testimony and they were
like what what that's not his laptop
it's a thumb drive
and it was all confusing and we mocked
it we made fun of it here
think about this for a second
about this for a second
break it down for one second
so Matt Gantz had a thumb drive
with Hunter Biden's lamp which is
supposed to be the most salacious most
uh harmful to iron democracy and tearing
down our constitution make sure Trump
whatever the
it's just a bunch of dick pics
from Hunter Biden and they're jealous
that his dick is bigger than the heirs
and his D they're just it's like Dustin
Dustin's jealous that Hunter Biden's
dick is bigger than his
twine yells and screams they yell and
scream about laptops
Matt gants is waving around a thumb
drive from a laptop
and we find out months later here we are
here we are
talking about thumb drives and laptops
at Mar-A-Lago
not at a Delaware home not at Mike
Pence's home nope none of that
none of that
we're talking about laptops and thumb
drives at Mar-A-Lago also other
classified documents that had to be
subpoenaed
they failed to mention that
they found other documents the attorneys
of Donald Trump and they didn't just go
hand them over like Jill Biden or Mike
Pence
the former vice president and the for
the president now
they had to subpoena for those documents
because he wouldn't turn them over
whoosh
so we're going to talk about that today
on the shitless Roundup now let's see we
have uh several more clips that I want
to um show here on the list Roundup
one from Glenn Greenwall Putin really is
uh leaning into turning up the volume
folks we have to take our game to 100 on
how loud we're being I don't know if you
know this or not but Putin is in a rough
situation here not only is he is he is
he not doing what he wanted to do in
Ukraine
um but he he also is losing all around
the world
uh with with democracy standing strong
I also want to talk about
um what we need to be
absolutely trumpeting
and and make sure our messaging and
narrative gets out
about the weaponization of government
because here's oh my God
here's another here's another projection
point that we found
is that yeah the government was used to
weaponize against private citizens
it was it was weaponized against private
citizens a lot
against Hillary Clinton
and others and they used Bill Barr and
Durham to do it in the Department of
Justice and I frankly we need to figure
out what the hell is going on we need to
figure out why why the government is
used to weaponize like that
we need to figure it out we need to get
to the bottom of the weaponization of
federal government how Bill Barr and
Durham
now weaponize their federal government
and now how the GOP is weaponizing the
government against Hunter Biden a
private citizen
and also against against
bureaucracy they're using it weaponizing
and just average everyday people who
work for the government FBI agents
people who worked at Twitter
really need to figure out what's going
on behind this GOP weaponization
we really should the other um the other
video I want to show you really plays
into the first 30 minutes when we talked
about the black national anthem and how
these white Christian nationalists Rio
America versus Nazis are offended by
that song
and they're really not offended by the
song because they're not going to listen
to it they're not going to listen to it
they're not going to read the lyrics if
you think Dustin over there on Facebook
is going to do any kind of searching to
make sure to see what the lyrics are and
read them to see what the songs
that you are wrong you are dead
wrong
Dustin's dumber than dog there's no
way that he would have any kind of
inclination to go and search
what those what the words to and the
lyrics to the song are what the original
poem is the let alone figure out that
that song was written as the black
national anthem almost 30 years before
it was said in the wall that the
Star-Spangled Banner was the national
anthem that he ain't gonna know
that he ain't gonna want to know that
ain't part of his nerd ain't part of his
delusion any part of his lie why would
he want to know that he doesn't want to
know anything that bangs up his
goddamn his goddamn whiteness and his
white privilege he didn't want to do
that that's scary that's scary when they
have to think about the truth it's
scary stuff
but I want to show you a statement made
by Martin Luther King Jr
to Dan Rather on CBS News
um about the Republican party and
becoming the white man's party
yeah you see I told you
I told you he's not going to do it see
Dustin he's not going to do it he the
truth is his enemy truth is these
people's enemy
and really truth and democracy is white
supremacy's enemy
that's why they're terrified of it
Freedom Liberty
rights it's all that's all their enemy
that's all their enemy Gabe Sanchez did
you check out I think I sent it to you
uh over the weekend this clip of Dr
Martin Luther King talking to Dan Rather
you're off again oh no you're you're
you're you're kind of like you're
cutting out is it just me yeah it's
definitely just me it's probably
definitely is it did you switch and it
changed your internet connection or
something
thank you
no yes you know I'll be right back yeah
yeah
oh
Sanchez Sanchez Sanchez he moved his um
his Studio around a bit in the room and
I believe what is happening
is that he's positioned himself in a way
that will not allow him to receive the
uh 5G signal from his booster
um that's the problem I think
um he needs to work on the um
the the secret Soros underground bunker
a little better maybe he'll get better
5G in that tunnel But there again there
was a clip um that the Tennessee holler
um posted uh this um
interview of Dan Rather where he
interviewed Martin Luther King Jr let's
see if that works how's that all right
we're good now better much better I
don't know I had to go from Wi-Fi to to
the direct cable see I told you I told
you your 5G booster just is not working
I know yeah which which one did you
get did you get the uh the Pfizer that's
probably why
you know it's more woke it's more awoke
than the other woke ones so that I know
I thought it was going to be the same
one that the M M's got but it turns out
it wasn't uh I was dead wrong I really
thought I really thought my first 30
minutes today I'd be talking about
Rihanna and woke Eminem commercials but
I had to talk about national anthem I
don't understand why this is not this is
not complicated you just do a few Google
searches and realize what that song that
that is referred to as the black
national anthem
um yeah well you know white people are
racist so well it right well it meant
some most yeah yeah okay okay all of
them are have these I mean can we not
can we not call out the fact that you
know Colin Kaepernick takes a knee which
is a respectful thing that a uh that a
veteran said hey if you're gonna if
you're gonna protest you're ringing the
national yeah during National take a
knee and then scary Carrie lake
has to sit like oh no I'm so butt hurt
I can't I can't stand for another minute
of listening music gracious to stand up
for this song I'm way too racist to
stand here for this one yeah have you
ever heard the phrase and you probably
have
um I'm not racist but have you ever
heard oh yeah yeah
you're like I I I I've literally heard
someone say this before these words I'm
not racist but I hate black people and
I'm like
um
um see I don't think you understand what
the word
racist actually means I don't think you
if we break this down yeah right the
core part of its race and it means that
you don't like a certain race right so
you've been like I don't like I look I'm
not racist but all right
I mean it was in the moment I was like
wow this is this is almost beautiful
that you're displaying your stupidity
and your racism all in one it's just a
yeah no it's honestly like uh it's a
nice little buttoned up package for you
and you're like oh wow this is the this
is this is great we are never getting
off this planet
well maybe we will maybe won't I want to
show this clip and the reason why I want
to show this clip uh Tennessee holler
posted this thing and I think I saw it
on Instagram first and that's right
right yeah yeah you shared with me yeah
and then I and then I went to Twitter to
see if they had posted on Twitter and
they had
um so I retweeted it
um but this really I I know I know these
two things don't seem connected right
yeah but them freaking out about a song
that was sung referred to as the black
national anthem and who is freaking out
about it the actual people who are
freaking out about it only makes and I
posted this and found this before that
happened I think I I think I sent this
to you like on Saturday I was like hey
make sure our Sunday morning like hey
make sure I talk about this during the
show don't let me forget I want to show
this clip but then as I watched as they
were freaking out this morning about the
black national anthem because they're
racist I was like whoa this clip fits in
perfect they're always
give a beautiful way for me to present
their racism right like and they're over
you know they're they're overt racism
it's an easy way to do it but listen to
what Martin Luther King and Dan Rather
are talking about here in this interview
this is you'll you'll catch why this has
to do
with this weekend's Super Bowl Dr King
in light of recent statements of Senator
Barry Goldwater and in some cases
Richard Nixon do you think there is a
real danger of the Republican Party
becoming the white man's party in this
country
I think this is a real danger and I've
talked with some negro Republicans who
are very concerned about this
okay just so everyone is clear
about the history of Martin Luther King
Jr Martin Luther King Jr is the
Godfather of woke by the way
um and that is why they refer to wokism
when it's black culture and black
national anthems and protests for black
lives matter and they call that woke
um
but he was a republican Gabe Sanchez
that's kind of the funny part about how
they have to like unwind Dr Martin
Luther King Jr and what they don't
realize is even though he was a
republican he saw and Dan Rather saw it
too to be quite honest
um that's why he was asking him about it
but they saw the potential for the party
switch during the Civil Rights Movement
right they saw this potential where
Nixon had um was was going to use in
later years was going to use the
southern strategy where he would go and
he would bleed into the racism of
Southern Democrats more than their party
affiliation
um and it would it would hoist that
modern Republican party to be what it is
but I want you to pay attention this is
really important what Martin Luther King
Jr says here what he says about Liberal
Republicans this is so key
listen
uh I see Trends and developments which
uh will reveal that unless the Liberals
of the Republican Party take a much more
play a much more decisive role in
leadership positions this will become a
white man's part and I think this would
be tragic for the Republican party as
well as tragic for the nation so he said
Not only would it be tragic for the
Republican party but tragic for the
nation and here we are in 2023 he said
the Liberals of the Republican Party see
a lot of people don't understand this
they don't understand like I don't know
history and they really it's hard
especially for gangs like Dustin over on
Facebook to go back and look at what
history is Dustin's our new fake game by
the way oh oh yeah yeah I think what did
I see I saw Dustin's asking something
about kisses he said do my kisses taste
like tacos and if you mean they taste
delicious uh yes they do
Dustin wants to kiss you it's I mean
honestly that was I didn't know who this
person was I saw the comment because
I'll briefly look at comments every once
in a while and I saw the comment and
said do Gabe's kisses taste like tacos
and at first I said oh man is this a fan
this guy knows that I like tacos yeah
and then I hear you talk about this guy
Dustin and I think oh no he's just a
racist yeah he took my name and said
well if his last name Sanchez of course
likes tacos and he probably always
smells like tacos I wish I always
smelled like tacos I wish
ah Destin you know what's better than
fake Gabe because fake game it was a
little hard because your name's Gabe you
know yeah yeah but Dustin oh my God you
couldn't get any better than maybe maybe
someone I got a new style ready no no
it's not called Dustin anymore yeah his
name is dust bin Dustbin Dustbin okay
Dustin
and he's out of the comments because
we're talking about him now and we must
make him feel really really small
[Music]
Dustbin white people invented tacos yeah
oh boy your racism is showing
there Desmond uh so this Martin Luther
King but what what the that that
Dustin doesn't really understand here's
what he doesn't understand is at one
point in our two-party systems history
there were liberals and conservatives
in both parties and the reason why that
is a thing is because of the definition
of liberal and conservative see we
walked away from what words actually
mean right like all these all these
people who want to absolutely get get
rid of democracy and get rid of
authoritarianism they're like oh we're
conservative Mike yeah but you don't
know what conservative means see see if
you were actually Conservative then
you'd want to conserve our state and
Status Quo as it is now you would not
want to progress it in a way that might
change it you want to conserve it and
keep it the same not change it like I
don't know get rid of democracy and
authoritarianism that's not conservative
it's not liberal either yeah because
liberalism is is the beacon of Freedom
the beacon of opportunity of choice like
that's the whole idea if you go look up
the word again they're just law us for
words here and they don't typically
understand the history again of our
two-party system that liberals and
conservatives used to live in the same
parties right that's how it worked
that's how it worked for a long time in
our democracy that's why there was such
a fight for the 13th Amendment in the
Republican Party during the civil war
that Abraham Lincoln worked so hard to
get the 13th Amendment passed because
there were liberals and conservatives in
both parties they called liberals
radicals but I mean you know just a
little change in language right
but here I think it's so significant
that Martin Luther King is concerned
that Liberals are leaving or not having
a voice in leadership in the Republican
Party
that it's going towards the the way of
fascism and racism and I think that
really speaks to where we're at in our
country and I think that the and this is
the reason why I talk about liberalism
the reason why I talk about Liberty so
much because I believe that if we can
change the narrative and change the
messaging where people believe in
liberalism that is strength that maybe
just maybe there may emerge a second
party
that is liberal
and maybe with conservatives where we
can have a situation where two parties
can exist with liberals and
conservatives inside those parties which
will make our system of a two-party
democracy a lot easier for our Republic
to operate
um but again it just speaks so loudly
that Martin Luther King during an
interview with Dan Rather
60 years 50 years ago over 50 years ago
right he's sitting there talking to him
and he doesn't even know that here we're
going to be in 2023 talking about how
racist are freaking out in 2023 because
black people got up and sang the black
national anthem I can't even it's
weird man it's weird that
they're so or even the fact that you
know Republicans got all butt hurt
everyone you know last year was Charlie
Kirk and his sexual Anarchy and this
year uh you've got uh Rihanna and she
goes up there being proud and Pregnant
you know you would think you would think
that Republicans would cheer that on you
think pro-life people would be happy you
would say oh my God this woman is
pregnant and she's she's promoting that
to the world you know I mean look
Rihanna obviously isn't you know 15 or
16 like Matt Walsh wants to be but she
is an adult who is in a relationship who
is having her second child and they get
so butt hurt God forbid that she wore
some sort of jumpsuit some some
maternity style uh outfit and
Republicans like oh my God oh my God how
dare she go out there public like that
oh my God that's disgusting meanwhile
white people are taking photos
wait wait why is this disgusting okay
number one Rihanna wasn't showing a
single bit of skin from the neck down
nope even her she had gloves on I think
that was intentional like she was she
was told everyone was in full like
full-on jumpsuits like you'd have to at
least four layers to get to the sexual
Anarchy you know right well now now I
will say that they get really confused
by the red because they're like oh
demons like you know what's funny is you
people talk about the Red Wave right
your party is right what the are
you like you were like there's gonna be
a red wave we're gonna stomp you we're
gonna bury you in a red wave like so
it's red is right I I never understood
what the hell I mean it doesn't make any
sense they never make any sense right
especially again we've got Dustin over
in the comments now he says I smell like
avocados that's fine honestly I mean
look if you want to be racist that's
your prerogative and that's you right
but at the same time it's like I love
avocados man you know what you know what
you should do you know what you should
you should come up with a fragrance
um Taco avocado avocado avocado yeah
something like that you know I mean if
it's like an avocado I gave Sanchez
it could be almost like the um
the Zoolander where he's like where he
does the merman commercial you know
right and just go through and like
you know Gabe Sanchez
oh my God but this is what they're
offended by
this this right here is now I mean
you know oh here Jane Doe has got some
uh ideas here we're gonna run with this
Taco avocado thing
I've seen fried I've seen fried avocados
before so I wouldn't be surprised if
somebody also made some sort of like
uh
tortilla out of avocado right like I
could I could imagine that somebody has
done that like they made the paste they
fried it I don't know how like together
it is so maybe it's more of like a flat
like you you eat it with a fork or
something it's not so foldable
I don't know if he's projecting here and
Dustin is I think he's forgettable I
would think somebody white like Dustin
that he would love well I think he I
think he's talking about creamy white
substances he's projecting here I think
that's what he's he doesn't like he
didn't like his crew which is weird
because he's cold he likes it hot
Straight From the Source probably yeah
right into the gullet he said that he he
said Dustin over here said um
the white man invented tacos which
that's hilarious that's great but if
it's the version with a ton of sour
cream then yeah just like well I mean I
mean he's like well Taco Bell is an
American I feel like maybe maybe he
thinks that the Taco Bell wasn't the
first right they were the first to the
taco right right
some white dude he's like Mexicans
Mexicans wrap that in a Crunchwrap
Supreme
so back to the uh the Red Demon here
Rihanna
um I actually thought that the um the
performance was really good I I'm not I
I have to admit I'm not I'm not a huge
Rihanna fan like I don't own her albums
or embodying your music but I mean I
like her music yeah yeah it's it's good
music I recognize it when I hear it you
know um I mean it's catchy it's catchy
stuff that's why she's I don't know at
the Super Bowl halftime show but the
thing that got me about the show was
like the different levels and stuff oh
yeah I was like that's good I was trying
to I was following along and I was like
typically when you put someone
especially someone who's pregnant uh at
that height you know you'll typically be
uh strapped on you'll have some sort of
support system or you'll sit in
um it's the same type of like little
brace that you'll like if you have
action figures there's like a stand and
you put their body in and it goes around
their torso
I've seen that as well but when I saw
her up on stage I was like damn I don't
see any of that stuff
right well and and that's the other
thing like
she's pregnant right and then where we
were at when we were watching the Super
Bowl all the when the dudes weren't
talking about it because you know that's
not a thing you should really do as a
dude like assume a woman's pregnant
that's the last time no yeah yeah even
if like you I had to go to Twitter
like holding her back and she's like oh
I'm about to have this baby you're gonna
be like are you pregnant like you don't
wanna there is a moment last night when
I was watching and I was like oh man
this is about to be the craziest gender
reveal party of all time right right and
then I was like I don't know if she
actually is pregnant but it seems like
she is and then everyone on Twitter was
like basically the same type of uh
feeling they're like is she is she not I
don't know it's not official it was and
so and then eventually somebody you know
links something and it was like oh it is
official she's having her second baby
with ASAP Rocky and then some people
like I guess that's why I call them ASAP
I mean a ton of jokes that were funny
because she just had a baby but she just
had a baby last year so some people were
like oh maybe it's still the baby way
and she's kind of owning it yeah
pregnant women are the strongest
creatures on Earth they can have a baby
and start having another one right after
I mean boom just like that can you
imagine if a guy had to have a baby
number one there is no I've only seen it
happen once and it was Arnold
Schwarzenegger yeah well that's a good
movie and even that I don't know how
that worked right yeah it's Hollywood
um but a man having a baby there's no
way any man on Earth is strong
enough to have a baby number one
number two no way would a man be
able to have two babies within two years
no way not even a possibility
even if we can make it scientifically
possible no dude would sign up to do
that no they're I mean
sometimes they sometimes the closest
thing you'll get to a man having a baby
is when they put on the uh electric stem
like machine they'll put them on on your
like lower abdomen area and they'll put
them on your stomach so that you can
feel the contractions and you can feel
the actual like stress that it puts on
your body
um and so uh I've seen videos of people
who are who try to who try to like go
through that simulation and even then
they like can't even make it like a few
like not even a minute like I want to
say like 20 seconds in that's the max
I've seen someone go before guys like
who'll take it he'll take it off correct
I can't do this and then you put it on
one month you put it on a woman
and they Crank that some up all
the way and she's nine months
you know whatever your however long
you're actually in labor in the hospital
because that obviously is even more
stressful and painful and anxiety and
just just total breakdown of your body
to bring this new life into the world
but no way a dude can do it in no way
would a guy be willing to do it you know
for the same reason that guy's like I'm
not willing to take uh you know if there
was like a
uh like a pill that you could take every
month right you know like there's birth
control for women but if there was birth
control for men I guarantee but oh I'm
not putting that in my body I don't know
what kind of chemicals are in there
meanwhile men are like you should take
his birth control and it's like well
okay man um the double standard bro
every time well and you know what I
noticed about this outfit and what the
conclusion I came to quietly that she
was pregnant as we were watching is that
she was intentionally I think she's
intentionally in the world know that she
has a baby bump right like I think
that's what she was doing I mean Kiki
Palmer went on to SNL and she announced
she was pregnant during her opening
monologue right she was like and I'm
pregnant you know and so you know this
is another way for a woman to right
exactly I think in a way it is that
empowerment like nobody can steal that
announcement from you to be like
breaking news Brianna is pregnant and
it's like yeah because she let you know
right she was pregnant
she could have zipped that that jumpsuit
up and no one would have known the
difference yeah like they might have
guessed but it wouldn't have been as
obvious to other women again guys out
there don't ever ever ever assume never
make the Assumption do not do that I've
stuck my foot my mouth once and I will
never ever I was really young I will
never ever ever ever do it again big
mistake you don't want to make that
mistake yeah but um you know I think is
also significant
um in the in the halftime show is that
here is a pregnant woman on these levels
and dancing around doing this big
routine on this humongous stage where
she had to move around a lot she was the
only one that performed she was the only
artist besides the it was her show and
that's all that happened which is not a
typical halftime show right like
typically they bring in other artists
um you know to get the crowd hyped and
get them going and keep the show moving
because it's well what is like a 20
minute 25 minute uh well no it's
actually well the full show goes 25 to
30 minutes right the actual performance
itself is like 13 minutes okay I was
reading before the show yesterday I was
like oh how long does it actually go on
for because I was trying to I was like I
typically know that the Super Bowl is
like four hours long did you watch the
entire super bowl or did you just watch
no I came a little bit later to a party
and then I had to and then I it was down
the street from my work and I were you
rooting for who were you I had no team I
had no no skin in the game we'll say
uh-huh
um that's an easy cop-out I mean I
didn't I didn't really why football this
year I mean I played in a couple fantasy
you know nothing about sports ball yeah
now I don't understand the sports balls
and things and so then you know but I
mean last year here in La was obviously
big because it was the Rams this year
was a little bit more tame uh it wasn't
as crazy as I saw some footage in Philly
oh my God they were like turning over
cars before the game before they were
like oh I was like oh god oh that's
crazy but uh yeah I caught most of the
Super Bowl and even then I was like at a
party and I was just like having drinks
and it was more of a social like oh
everyone's here and we've got it playing
and some people are watching but most of
it's just like in the background because
we're all like we're making a friend
just got one of those uni pizza ovens so
we were making like uh handmade pizzas
and just drinking beer and having this
and having that girl scout cookies
because it's Girl Scout cookie season so
you had you had pizza breath and pizza
kisses yeah I had pizza kisses uh
oh my God Justin what a dumb I'm
Dustbin here here is the uh
moment that a lot of people were talking
about at the halftime show where she
stopped to adjust her makeup oh yeah
yeah in the middle of the song obviously
I think this was part of the
choreographed dance
um but um it got a lot of people going
here the only reason why I want to point
this out is because she did
for for all you conservative real
America First Nazis out there that get
offended by women's skin you do not want
to look at this picture because she did
have her gloves off and she is showing
the skin of her arms and her hands and
she's also showing her nails here which
you know really might get these weirdos
going yeah um so I just want to warn
give a trigger a warning for all the for
all the dip shits out there that this
shows more skin than just the neck up
right um which was not a theme of the
halftime show it was and yet and over
the so over the weekend they were they
were playing obviously a lot of music I
think and on Saturday on a few stations
out here in La it was just like rolling
through a lot of her a lot of the hits
that she's had over the years because I
mean I was thinking I was talking back
with my partner and we were like oh like
what was the what was the first song and
I was like oh it was the it was summer
of 2005 and I just gotten my license and
I was driving around and that and her
first song where she's in the club and
um
I just had one of those moments where
it's like you hear something you know
and you instantly have like Nostalgia
and I was like oh it was summer and I
was driving my mom's Minivan and I was I
was like I got my license and that was
the song I was playing that song wait
wait it was like did you lean the seat
back and put your arm up on the steering
wheel and you were like thumping to it
is it with the windows down no at that
point I was not as tall as I was now you
know so like the distance of the
steering wheel might be a little too
much Pawn to replay that's what it is
thank you KT Rose I knew I was like it's
in my head here I just just uh just had
it anyways that was her that was like
the first song that she was discovered
with and it was the big song that went
went viral but I was we went back and I
was like oh my God this is a hit and
this is it I forgot about this song and
that song and so it was cool to kind of
see her go through from 2005 almost 20
years of music I mean 18 years right now
that's an adult that is an adult crazy
worth of life right there which is a I
mean it's so impressive and so yeah why
never people like oh why didn't they
have guests or why didn't this person
come out or whatever and it's like dude
she doesn't need anyone right she
carries your own she's also carrying
another person she's golden
right you ass she
can handle this now you know some
people were like oh Kanye should come
out and I'm like no no no no no yeah
right you know you know who can't handle
it you know again yes
this guy's really butt hurt about
Rihanna he's probably a little mad that
like
this is real by the way no yeah I know I
know that it's it is it is insane but I
I honestly think that he was a little
pissed at like
um you know there wasn't a white country
even though who knows if he actually
listen to that uh racist person out
there he's like oh man this should have
been that should have that should that
should be the you know that should be
that that should be the uh the halftime
sticker I don't know why I'm making him
sound like that
gave his hinges listen this is the guy
who goes out on stage and does the draft
jack off dance yeah the YMCA of two
ghosts right this is he he does that
dance to YMCA and doesn't even
understand what the song The
Lion the YMCA is about
what they're saying about the men in the
anyways I mean you would have to like go
look up and see the lyrics and the
point of the song and the people but
that would assume that Donald Trump
could read you know right well right or
just understand any kind of rational
thought I mean it presents it here well
um that he has no idea what you know
anything objectively is as far as good
and not good he says epic fail oh my God
in large camp and he's going to describe
as what the epic fail is here Rihanna
gave without question I I believe
there's a little bit there uh question
that is debatable right the single worst
halftime show in Super Bowl history you
are such a dumb and then he goes
which honestly
I have never watched a Super Bowl
halftime show and went that wasn't that
was pretty sweet that's a free I can't
even believe that they they're giving
that away for free on network television
all they're gonna do is watch a couple
Pepsi commercials and I get to you know
bam there it is yeah almost all of them
are objectively good
um yeah so I mean the road of thousands
of people right right and it goes on to
say this after insulting far more than
half of our nation here's what he's
referring to Rihanna hates Trump
and the reason why she hates Trump uh
Gabe Sanchez is because he's a
racist oh yeah yeah he doesn't she
doesn't like Trump because he's a
racist right the same reason why
uh Christy Teigen called him a ass
yeah is because he is a ass
and he's being a ass
in this post ass 45 PAB 45
by the way we're gonna be we're getting
some ideas for Merch together for pab45
we're getting close to a couple
different designs so everyone this week
will be rolling out a couple different
designs for ass 45. anyways
back to the ass post here
he says which is already in serious
decline he believes our nun our country
is he hates our country yep he
he hates he hates the push for
democracy he hates for the push for
human rights for women's rights he hates
that he hates that because it feels like
to him when when white male privileges
challenge that he's oppressed yeah
ass
he goes on to say he's not done yet by
the way with her foul and insulting
language oh my God oh my God the guy
that uses curse words and talks about
grabbing women by their is is
terrified and scared of Rihanna using
Fallon insulting language there's a
there's a photo of Rihanna where she
does she's got her hand over her over
her crotch oh and so when I when I see
Republicans online today be like oh my
God how dare I saw someone
I saw someone actually on the left who
got so butt hurt and at first I
thought I was like oh this is a joke
this is a this is a whole bit and then
as I'm reading through the comments I'm
like oh no this is this person is really
triggered by this they're like I had to
turn off the TV because it was you know
because there she was launching her
pregnant body grabbing our gosh what do
you think and she's like in my kids out
of state I'm like do you honestly think
that your kid's gonna see her and be
like oh my God I'm getting pregnant now
no that is not how it works but also
everyone questioned that she was
pregnant in the first place yeah and the
fact that you know she does that with
her own of her own body she does
whatever she wants because again
that's what she is that's that's her
that's her thing and she owns that and
so when you have someone who's like oh
my God how dare she grabs her crotch
like that or do this or like just do a
hand motion it's like
this dude who was president
bragged about sexually assaulting women
and then not only that but then recently
wow
he can grab her by the she can't
grab her own but right your body got it
my choice right exactly all right you
see that's where you're going wrong here
on this you know guys
you're right I'm trying to make these
apples to apples have you ever seen have
you ever watched the the video of Kirk
Cameron talking about Christianity and
he's like well you have to do is you
have to circumvent you have to
circumvent people's logic
every single time we talk about these
I think about that clip of
Kirk Cameron be like look the way to
brainwash people is you have to
circumvent their logic and really
convince them that it's their logic that
is confusing them okay so that the very
end here he has to go in for one more
dig right yeah because he can't he he's
really upset that he didn't get to see
Rihanna half naked I believe that's what
he's that's why he's pissed off yeah
he's like I didn't see any skin outside
of her hands and her face right I didn't
I well you know we got to see Janet
Jackson's nipple but Mariana and I was I
was look I was hoping
for a nipple gate again but you know
that's just me
um I think Brianna's beautiful but he
says here at the end he says also so
much for her stylist
um
all right which I don't know if you guys
if you guys watched the video of the
black national anthem where Carrie late
got butt hurt
um or not but the the the costuming the
the the styling was the same as the
halftime show I don't know I don't know
if you saw that foreshadowing
um from the from the the
pregame show and the halftime show but
if you if you watch both you saw the
foreshadowing there of The Styling but
you know who am I who am I to look at
Art and go oh oh they're being creative
I mean who I mean also who are we to or
rather who is Trump to talk about a
stylist when he's the guy who goes to
his tailor and says hey can you give me
the longest jacket possible the longest
tie possible
I can look tall and I can look slim you
know like that is not that should not be
the guy that's talking at all I mean the
guy who's a racist a xenophobe a
complete idiot and someone who has
terrible Style with his comb
over wafting back hair whatever it might
be like the guy is someone who should
just never open his mouth again because
everything he says is either a
confession
or just a revealing part of him being an
idiot oh we're gonna get to that we're
going to get to the lab job from Hell
the actual laptop yeah uh eventually
here but um one other thing I want to
show about the uh Super Bowl and the
National Anthem Part is this um this
tweet
from the petty Yeti the petty Eddie
tweets and I don't you know obviously
she doesn't
um know how to use Google
um and she doesn't know what Chris
Stapleton actually stands for and the
things he's actually spoke out about
about wokism and wokeness
but Marjorie huffit green Formerly Known
now known as the petty Yeti because of
her behavior at the State of the Union
Address thank you by the way um Petty
Eddie for giving us the opportunity to
give you that nickname she says Chris
Stapleton just sang the most beautiful
national anthem at the Super Bowl now
I didn't listen in real time to the
pre-game shows we had to eat before and
then we went somewhere else to launch
the game and
I so I didn't watch the the the pre-game
shows until uh this morning Chris
Stapleton did a great job Chris
Stapleton is a great artist if you've
ever heard him sing any of his versions
of Tennessee whiskey you know that Chris
Stapleton is a very talented artist now
back in the year 2000 This was um during
the height of the black lives matter
movement after George Floyd yeah excuse
me 2020. yeah um um back when um George
Floyd had been murdered by Derek Chauvin
um he went on CBS This Morning
and he was asked about this and Chris
Stapleton said black lives absolutely
matter and not only did he say that he
said he stands by
those statements he stands by those
statements which to the petty Eddie that
should be full on wokeness wouldn't you
wouldn't you think yeah uh I would go in
the fact that if Chris Stapleton Chris
Stapleton said he has no regrets about
his Pro BRAC black lives matter comments
and saying he was in support and that we
should have that and that is something
that is that is should be discussed
it's like uh into funny the funny thing
about this it actually takes me back I
did a sketch that was about all the
things that Republicans canceled right
and it was a wall of just logos and it
was like Pepsi and Home Depot and this
and that and it was like basically me
and another character myself talking
about what what could we have right and
we're like well let's just put on some
Chris Stapleton he's like can't he's
pro-black lives matter and it's just
another one of those things where it's
like they try they run down a list of
and and now maybe two years later they
totally forget that this guy is is four
right because they freaked out at the
time yeah like they were really pissed
off that a country artist as talented as
Chris Stapleton has as many awards as
Chris Stapleton who looks like Chris
Stapleton look because it really bangs
up the whole idea oh yeah at a white
dude with a big beard dressing in the
cowboy hat and Country clothes or
whatever and having the accent that he
has it really bangs up the idea that
that white is right right they just they
just can't can't handle that image
that's why I pissed Dustin off
that's why I pissed Dustin off it pisses
him off that I'm a liberal and and how I
sound and how I look like it pisses him
off and my backstory and my experience
because I'm sure Chris stapleton's
experience is very similar to mine
because Chris Stapleton in his
statements since 2020 has said that he
was duped he didn't actually he didn't
actually know the country that he lived
in he didn't understand the country they
lived in and that's why he came to these
conclusions not not because Chris
Stapleton listened to the media because
Chris Stapleton understood that he
should use rational thought and logical
thinking to go look at the history and
look at what happened in this country
that he wasn't told about the truth the
truth and he was able to form a
decent opinion around the truth now no
one's perfect Chris stapleton's not
perfect and he never will I'm not
perfect Gabe's not perfect and I'm sure
Chris Stapleton is held very bigot abuse
from his childhood that were instituted
in him just like I held bigoted views
that I didn't understand until I got I
don't know reached the Age of Reason and
I could reason away the fact that I was
lied to and mind right by the
institution of white supremacy like
Dustin is is mind by the
institution of white supremacy but
speaking of the institutional white
supremacy
the petty Eddie goes on to tweet here
and this is the best part this is the
best part but we could have gone without
the rest of the wokeness she means she
means the the crowd of n words is what
she means it's what she means and I want
to show you this tweet
um
I'll read this here from professor
professor uh Enya I think it's how you
say the name
um
and and I want to read this and I want
to warn you she says the n-word I'm not
going to say it but it's up on the
screen yeah we might get kicked from
YouTube for me showing you this
tweet to be quite honest because it has
the n-word in it but I like that she did
not censor it actually and there's a
reason why in this moment that I'm glad
she did not censor this word is because
she's trying to make a full-on point of
what marjor Taylor green is saying here
and she's absolutely spot on I I played
a video the other day uh during uh
desegregation and during the Civil
Rights Movement when white people were
really upset that black people wouldn't
go on their side of the town and they
could go on their side of town and they
should they should agree that the white
man made this country and blah blah blah
we played that clip
and I said this is what they mean by
make America great again make America
white again is what they actually mean
and this is what she surmises that woke
means and in this tweet from Marjorie
Taylor green he doesn't understand
Chris stapleton's views at all at all
and and well she sees a guy that sings
country music and his wife white guy
looks like he does and he goes he must
be on my side you know right and he's
right he must be right racist
again that's what confuses these
boneheads with me but but also you know
something you brought up earlier which
is like you know he felt like he was
duped during that time and I I do think
that is you know for some people
especially within you know who are white
uh took
actually were you know actually had
their eyes open and actually were
willing to listen and being open-minded
and Shane oh this was
not what I thought it was right like I
this is really up and now I want
to hear what those marginalized
communities have to say and I want to be
better
I want to be you know anti-racist I want
to be more respectful I want to be a
better Ally and in any way that I can
whether it's just me being me just
saying I'm for uh you know I'm Pro BLM
right because their lives do matter or
if it's actually you know marching or
it's donating or whatever it might be
and so
margin Taylor green sees those three
things and she goes yep I can assume
that this man is on my side and that
really shows you how dumb these people
are because they don't actually I don't
think have a sense of of of of
remembering or they just you know they
don't have an ability to kind of realize
what other people that may look like
them may have differing points of view
right and they might be like oh this
actually this person actually does care
about other people does care about the
human race not just about a white race
right and and Marjorie Taylor green is
another person who you know just like
Donald Trump was like oh I couldn't care
for it put a white person up there as a
performer and I would I would love it
you know and that's what that's what
they're saying it's really up
it's so up and I want to read
this tweet it says so
what came before the white man sang the
ARP excuse me what came before the white
man sang the national anthem that she
wished wasn't there black people black
music Black Culture
I have been telling y'all when white
conservatives say woke they mean the
n-word
now I want to point something out here
and this is what Chris Stapleton
understands that Marjorie Taylor Greene
does not under she doesn't get
it she doesn't get it
the reason why Chris Stapleton is such a
good artist and I I don't know Have you
listened to Chris Stapleton sing much
um I mean I'm not a country
fan okay well I don't I don't listen to
it often even even if even if you're not
a country music fan Chris Stapleton and
his voice
I don't know if you if you listen to the
inflection of his voice it's not he
ain't got no twine to it like George
Jones He Stopped Loving Her no he
doesn't have that it's a very Soulful
voice he uses soul and Blues in his
voice he's a he plays Blues on the
guitar
and if anyone
if anyone would just for a second
understand where those sounds come from
those sounds do not come from White
culture they do not come from White
music they come from black people black
music and Black Culture that is why I
believe
that Chris Stapleton came to the
conclusion that black lives absolutely
do matter
and that Chris Stapleton understood that
I was lied to the institution lied to me
I had been appropriating black culture
and stealing Black Culture my entire
life without even knowing it
and that is the truth about Chris
Stapleton because without black people
without black music without Black
Culture that national anthem
from Chris Stapleton would have not been
the most beautiful national anthem at
the Super Bowl which is debatable it was
really good Chris Stapleton did a
fantastic job of saying that I didn't
watch it but I well I mean it's up there
it's up there with Marvin Gaye it's up
there with Whitney Houston's version I
mean there's a lot of shitty versions of
the national anthem you know we're
talking about the cheetah that's q9 is
talking about halftime shows that were
bad there's a lot of worst when it comes
to National Anthem Renditions
um at any kind of sporting event but the
Super Bowl in particular but Chris
Stapleton is at least in the top ten if
not in the top five it was it
was a great great job and the reason why
Marjorie Taylor green it was a great job
is because he used Soul and Blues in
that song from black people
black music and Black Culture you
bigoted ass racist I just wanted
to make sure to make that clear yeah I
just want to make that clear you
actually bring up a good point I I just
sent you a video that I uh I think you
might have seen it kind of made the
rounds I think on Saturday and Sunday
and of course it you know even before
she said what she said you know in her
tweet of the Super Bowl that's what she
said
but it honestly did play out uh and this
is a clip of
you know taken
from one of her many many diatribes on
on
Twitter or Facebook well no somebody
pulled it and made it a tick tock
because somebody said that she had this
thing and they pulled up an old clip uh
but it's one of those I forgot I'm if I
had to assume this is like
the same time period when she was like
oh we got Malik and we got the Democrats
and their and they got this Global
conspiracy this cable as she as she
called it face lasers
this is I think this is the time when
she was wait wait wait wait I went at
the audience to understand the petty
Eddie says cabal yeah has cable right
just like she says Peach Tree dish right
or gazpacho which you know I make fun of
her mocker but yeah people can do the
same thing to me because I say words
weird like salsa yeah but you're not a
city member of Congress so that is true
hey what the you don't think I I
wouldn't I'm not saying that you could
I'm just saying that maybe oh I
definitely I definitely could be if I
switch my ideology and switch my oh yeah
probably oh my God man you need to run a
whole campaign and not even not even
take office but just Griffin right right
but I mean you know if I was hey maybe
if I was in it for the money that's what
I should do anyways the point is is that
if she could be if this dumb ass could
be a member of Congress any dumb ass
could be a member of Congress I don't
even know what this video is so I hope
it's good uh let's let's check out what
Gabe send us here I know a ton of white
people that are as lazy and sorry and
and probably worse than black people I
know
um Gabe Sanchez I've talked about this
before
now I know if you need any more than
that man I uh why I've talked about this
before and this this is what she's
talking about this is the whole this is
the whole reason why she tweeted that
racist that about about wokeness
when she means Blackness right what she
means yeah
um well she's like any any sort of
equality or equity for anyone else that
isn't white people that's woke and woke
is bad and that's why you have Ron
DeSantis being like what goes to die
it's like oh man if you couldn't be
anybody Liberty Liberty is woke Liberty
is woke it's more woke than Eminem's
genitalia okay so here's what she's
saying here and I've talked about this
several times before and we're gonna
keep repeating this the same
thing
is in white communities in rural White
America there are no people of color
when I grew up I grew up in White
America there were no people coloring
our community there just weren't and we
were racist as the institution was
raced as but there was no one there
was let me let me slow down there was no
one to be racist against in our
community right they weren't in our
community they didn't want I mean why
would they want to be in our community
they weren't welcome in our community
there was no people of color so what
happened was is you would use the
institution of racism and frame it up as
classism right and that's what she's
really talking about here
um it was put to me a certain way when I
was a kid
the same sentiment just with the n-word
invoked
and they would say something like well
it's not bad to be an n-word because
there's white inwards
right N word means trash is a lot of
times the way it would be put to you and
that is the classism that she's talking
about here that is the classic
institution of racism living inside
Marjorie Taylor Green's white community
that has no people of color that she
can't express her absolute racism
bigotry on directly she has to express
that towards you know the Trashy white
people in other words in other words
they're not as bad as those black folks
gave Sanchez but you know they live on
the wrong side of town right yeah so we
consider them our inwards and that is
what she's talking about I'll play it
one more time if you don't believe me
let's play it one more time it's not
that long
I know a ton of white people that are as
lazy and sorry and and probably worse
than black people I know
oh my God whoosh and if you don't
believe me I mean I've said it before a
time and time again on this show and
Texas Paul has talked about it too
that's exactly what is happening inside
this little maggot's brain
is that she's still living in the
institution of her little white
town she has no concept of how
this country is made how it's built how
the appropriation of black music black
people and black culture is all
sold and commercialized by white people
she doesn't understand it she
doesn't get it it's stolen and she just
she doesn't understand it and she
doesn't understand the words
um to this national anthem the black
national anthem uh I talked about it in
the first 30 minutes but I want to give
you the first three lines again the song
is called lift every voice and sing
right it's not called we're gonna get
revenge right that's what they want it
to be called that's the sentiment that
they want it to predict we're gonna get
revenge because here's the thing those
people who are projecting that fear
or the insecurity that they have onto
other people like you know the black
community is because they know they know
they were in the wrong they know that
they still are in the wrong and then
it's not the common consensus
for people and what they where they are
in in the US right because you know I
would say that there are more people who
want equity and equality for you know a
larger group of people not just white
people and they're a small small group
of these white people who feel very
insecure very insecure if anyone ever
gets a little sliver more of the pie
than them right because they go Oh no
you're taking away from me I'm oppressed
I'm the real victim here that is the
game they play
and so when they ever see something any
opportunity for another group to get
their Spotlight in a good way
they say oh no that's unfair that's that
is totally woke and that's that is anti
that is Reverse Racism
and it's like no no it's not at all it's
a lot of ass yeah it's
very very triggered sensitive snowflake
all the things that Republicans call
Democrats and liberals and leftists and
all that it actually is just
them projecting their own insecurity
onto another group so they don't have to
feel or look so scared right the same
reason that Tucker Carlson does what he
does well and this is this and this is
why the clip that we just watched for
marjor Taylor green is because honestly
in in her community she probably was the
ones that lived on the wrong side of the
town oh guarantee I might be a dumb
white person but at least I'm not a you
remember I'm not racist but I hate black
people right same Cut From the Same
Cloth but let me read you let me read
you the first three lines to this song
now again this was this poem was written
in at the turn of the century in the
year 1900 it was put the music in 19
0.05 that was 11 years before Woodrow
Wilson wrote an executive order to make
the Star-Spangled Banner the national
anthem that was until 1931 it was not
set in the law that the Star-Spangled
Banner was the national anthem they sang
many other songs as the national anthem
right now here's the first three words
to lift every voice and sing it's not a
Marjorie it's not called we want revenge
Kerry Lake it's not called we want
revenge it's called lift every voice and
sing here's the lyrics lift every voice
and sing till Earth and Heaven ring ring
with the harmonies of Liberty
I just I I can't I can't get over that
they're butt hurt about these
words listen again these these
people who self-proclaim them as some
kind of Jesus follower and all this
nonsense lift every voice and
sing tell Earth and Heaven ring ring
with harmonies of Liberty I guess is
there anything woke in there well you
know I if that I'm almost positive all
of those things are hit in the national
anthem if that's woke if that's
woke count me the in man
yeah even at me as an atheist I do not
have a problem with people believing
that there's an afterlife and that
there's a heaven that they can go to to
see their relatives whatever makes you
need to get through day to day because I
understand that a human beings need a
lot to get through their day-to-day and
if it's religion and faith and believing
there's a heaven hey I'm all for it I
don't give a what religion it is
either or or if you don't need religion
I'm all for that but when you talk about
Liberty in the first three months of
this song was written in the year 1900
Gabe Sanchez before this morning I had
not on my radar the lyrics to this
song
and I believe
that that this song invokes Faith and
Jesus and Christianity yeah to make sure
that that after the Civil War after the
emancipation of slaves now you got to
remember
there was a lot of back and forth after
the Civil War and they were they were
emancipated they were freed
um in a lot of places the the black men
were allowed to vote and that's when the
idea of the white man in the South went
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa you said they
were you said they weren't going to be
slaves but you said nothing about them
being free and having Liberty that
you can't have liberty no no no you
can be free and not be slaves but you
don't get to have money you
don't get to have a job you don't get to
have an education you are not free in
this country
that's that is what the the southern
whites believed and they made sure to
Institute segregation in the South to
make sure that black people did not have
their Liberty
and even in the face of that it didn't
matter it didn't matter that that I I'll
read you some more I'll read you some
more Let me let me see um
let me see here there's there's a part
about Slaughter here here's here's uh
here's the part we have come over away
that with tears
has been watered we have come
treading our path through the blood of
the slaughtered
out from the gloomy past till now we
stand at last where the white gleam of
our bright star cast
God of our weary ears God of our silent
tears thou who brought us thus far on
the way I just I can't understand why
you can't look at the words this song
and understand what what they're saying
well I guarantee that if you were to
have someone who is white let's say that
it was Chris Stapleton right and he was
singing that song
I guarantee Republicans would be like oh
yeah
I think first off that is a brilliant
that's brilliant I think this is what
can happen is if he's saying it they
would not only go like oh yes I will
stand for this but also they'd be like
oh is this an original right like they
would honestly I mean they never knew
about what the song was he said God
three times he said Liberty
like oh my gosh of course those would be
the two outcomes one that would really
enjoy it and the second is they would
think that Chris Stapleton was actually
the original Creator like oh my God he's
debuting an original song just for us
he's going back to back anthems
you know that is that is brilliant I I
didn't think about that and maybe maybe
the um maybe the organizers at the Super
Bowl didn't realize that they should
have switched the artist
um and it would have changed the
conversation
right it would have it it would have
been interesting to see Republicans be
like man that was a beautiful song and
then you find out what it is and then
they're like oh well
uh I mean let's find out to find out
that that song from Chris Stapleton just
sang with like oh it's the greatest he
did the national anthem and he did this
other great song you're like that's
actually the black national anthem yeah
I mean
just heads would explode man
there is a there is a part of me which I
would have been like that would have
made it even better
to have them step in that pile of
really waffle it through their
toes and then realize
oh actually it wasn't an original and it
wasn't written by a white person and it
actually was the black national anthem
and you guys just stood for it applauded
it cried your eyes out because you
thought it was beautiful
joke's on you because now that woke song
that wokeism you guys were clapping for
it you guys loved it
well and that really is the trickery of
these people because they always have to
be against something right and they
always have to be against something uh
speaking of people who use the trickery
and deceit of Mind and delusion
look at these two here's a picture taken
from the Super Bowl
it is uh Mr Elon Musk the head and
Rupert Murdoch himself the uh the the
blood cult leader of the propaganda arm
that is the Trump cult
um sitting together at the Super Bowl I
wonder what ideas they were trading or
if they were just like you're doing a
great you're doing it yeah was Murdoch
Rupert Murdoch even awake
this guy was dead but I I I think the
idea they'll live to be 140. I didn't
know that I don't know I'm he's just a
walking skeleton this point I mean the
guy
you know and Elon Musk specifically like
this guy says
um it's better to have Republicans own
you know and have the majority in the in
the house right that would allow for
this independent kind of balance that we
need in in politics right but then you
have them at the
uh World Cup and he's meeting with the
Saudi investors he's got Jared Kushner
over there with his two billion
investment and then well and and
apparently apparently a thumbnail Drive
in his pocket possibly yeah I'm just I'm
just pointing out that it would be very
easy for Jared Kushner to carry a thumb
drive in his pocket to the World Cup I
saw someone I saw someone on Twitter
today they uh I think it might have uh I
think it was a a person that I follow
named Larry uh it had ass on Elon and
hole on Rupert Murdoch yeah that's not
it's not a bad description that's really
not a bad description of of that picture
yes
um so I want to play one more clip that
doesn't have to do with what we're
talking about other than Rupert
Murdoch and Elon Musk trying to
absolutely bang up democracy uh post
left watch had this video
um of uh Glenn Greenwald are you
familiar with Glenn Greenwald at all
yeah I try to forget him whenever I can
okay well we we can't we we have to pay
attention because he is Putin's puppet
here right
um
he's talking about uh the the uh hasad
regime
and in Syria and and chemical weapons
now they've been making these stupid
false claims
um that that hassad did not use chemical
weapons even though we have proof that
they did that he did he did not use
clinical weapons on his own people and
and again his logic
um is pointed towards Putin
um and I I said that Putin is turning up
the volume folks I I don't know if
you've noticed this but Putin is turning
up the volume for 2024. he's in big
trouble I mean big
trouble his only bet and best bet to
survive as the authoritarian
leader of Russia and be and still remain
a murderous dictator
and murdering innocent civilians
in a sovereign country which he's trying
to take over the only way for him to do
that is to make sure Donald Trump is the
president United States right that's the
only way so he's turning up the volume
and we need to get ready to go to level
100 I mean we're at like I mean I'm
always at level 100. actually I'm kind
of extra I'm at like 120 probably I mean
I try to be I try to be extra I try to
be it's a habit of mine but
left-wing watch has here I don't know if
this is a I guess this is a podcast that
this guy does
I don't know I've never seen this I've
never seen this studio before so well I
think it's a green screen I think it's a
green screen and one thing I'll point
out that when I was watching this I was
thinking about you game like his the the
graphic that he has here on the screen
just is not big enough
it's something it looks unbalanced
yeah you would think someone who's been
in the media as long as Glenn Greenwald
any any I mean this is not a bad green
screen it's kind of terrible are you
sure he's actually in front of a green
screen
oh yeah it's a green screen you can't
tell that from his hair well it
depends he's got he's got key light
going on and then he's also got like
backlit so that he's got a little
background I don't know it's hard to say
maybe he's in front of your machine I
don't know or maybe it's maybe it's a
screen that is
animated I don't know no this is damn
I'll send you the video and you can zoom
in and evaluate I'm telling you it's a
green screen this game
definitely is doing green screen here
and it's not great green screen but it's
it's all right uh it's all right it's
not bad but again if you look at this
objectively this graphic here is way too
small and he's very small he's he should
be over over a little bit make the
graphic bigger right it's just standard
it's like look you're not Reinventing
the wheel here all right like everyone
else does it right right I mean like
when you're on the full screen change
your camera angle make yourself over to
the side make your graphic bigger so
everyone can see the graphic and then if
you want to switch back to the other
camera angle when you're in the center
you do that right who am I to say though
I mean who am I to say really but you
know okay so here is
here is Glenn Greenwald listen to what
this scumbag says and he invokes Thomas
Massey in this which is even more
disgusting
um that he's like oh my go-to
information is Thomas Massey when's
lizard
now one of the things that's remarkable
about Seymour Hirsch's story is not so
much what he said but where he said it
note that he published it on sub stack
and that's because Seymour Hersh has
essentially been expelled from
mainstream media circles
okay this is this is more of the whole
hey his is garbage like he's
garbage that's why no one wants to give
him a voice he's been pushed out by the
mainstream media because he's a lying
sack of I mean like that's the
first thing I think of I mean they put a
lot a lot of line sacks of on
mainstream media a lot of them yeah yeah
like they want a lot of Republicans
you could go from the first
show in the morning on Fox News all the
way into the night and you can be like
yep batting a thousand dollars shitty
people on the TV right now right right
and it's it's it's not like no one's
watching when those scumbags are
on Fox News Ohan or Newsmax spouting
their lies but let's continue
here wish.com Tucker Carlson let's let's
go after this incredibly illustrious
career breaking more major stories than
almost every major every employee of
major media corporations combined his
last mainstream story in a mainstream
Outlet was a 2017 article in the New
Yorker alleging that the U.S government
was wrong in claiming that Bashar
al-assad the Syrian leader he used
chemical weapons on his own people okay
this is why he has to say this okay
Glenn green won't have to say allegedly
uh that the government was wrong because
they're right they're right this guy is
just alleging it that's it
I'm not I'm not spreading any rumors
here but religion I'm not spreading any
rumors that Jared Kushner put a thumb
drive in his pocket and went and uh
stuck it in a saudi's laptop to copy
files and then took it back and stashed
it Mar-A-Lago I'm just saying it seems
like that could happen right now again
am I spreading conspiracy theories yeah
but I'm a commentator I'm not I'm not
being published in New Yorker folks I'm
the circus clown of the left I
know that you know that it's the whole
point that's all point in this
show but the other point is is that
Glenn Greenwald doesn't understand that
they're not just gonna willy-nilly let
some idiot who's alleging
whatever he wants to allege because it
feels good to him and it's good for for
Putin's narrative to have him
trudged all over all over the
mainstream media let's continue with
Putin's puppet here he questioned that
claim just the way that for example
Congressman Thomas Massey recently did
it interviewed we showed you back in
2017 when CNN was interviewing Massey
about why he opposed U.S intervention in
Syria why he opposed U.S regime change
efforts in Syria there it is there's his
evidence of why he's wrong so basically
what What Glenn Greenwald is saying is
there was an article written that
alleged stories
that somehow the government was wrong
when they alleged that Assad used
chemical weapons on his own people and
then he says on CNN not Fox News
not some Trader TV News Network on CNN a
scumbag a lying Republican
scumbag like Thomas Massey can come
repeat that live on the air in the
moment you're only proving your point
wrong Glenn you're only proving yourself
wrong that in the moment when Thomas
Massey went on CNN to say that someone
fat checked that and then
went nope we're not doing that no
more we're not talking about that
anymore that's a that's
that's all nonsense and just
because you're not willing to
spread a lie grin Glenn Greenwald
doesn't mean you're being canceled or
he's being canceled you're just pieces
of you're just pieces of
trash that are spreading around trashy
garbage lies that's it that's it why the
he he runs right smack dab into it
in his whole diet tribe here I
mean anyone anyone who's gonna who's
going to you know uh put a bunch of
rumors or falsehoods out there and then
as soon as somebody goes oh actually I
just I just did a simple Google search
and uh we found that this was totally
inaccurate I mean like basically when
Republicans are fact checked and they're
called out to be like actually what you
just said was inherently just
totally false easily checkable too they
go they go whoa whoa whoa why are you
guys attacking me why are you why guys
don't be so mean Jesus wants you to love
your enemies but anyway it's like you
know what did Jesus say when you're when
when you know when somebody slaps you
you turn the other cheek like that's
Republicans right there they're like
well I can't take it you know I can dish
it but I can't take it you know all this
I'm so well I'm such the victim here and
you've got like Damon Damon Ace as over
here he thinks he's Mr Rogers with that
freaking sweater and tying and shirt on
oh a hundred percent now
it's just a little whiny who yes
of course runs right into the point to
prove exactly why they were kicked off
these stations or why no one would trust
their opinion on actual mainstream media
because at a certain point just like Fox
was like ah we can't talk about his
election anymore right we can't do
the Dominion stuff we're gonna get sued
they know that there is a certain extent
to which you can be like allegedly but
as soon as we have 100 verifiable facts
that can prove this wrong it's no longer
a legend it's just misinformation or
it's a falsehood or it's just complete
lies and if you continue to spread it
with something that is com that has been
debunked or disproven then yeah you are
going to be sued or held liable
for defamation on the things that you
say and so the reason they don't want
them on the show is because they're like
yeah this guy's too much of a risk too
much of a liability to say something off
the cuff that's going to cost us
Millions if not billions of dollars down
the road or our credibility for that
right I mean Amanda credibility to have
right well Amanda says freedom of lies
and that's really what Glenn Greenwald
wants he wants Freedom life so he can
push
um Putin's propaganda now I want to
point something out and Glenn and I know
I always talk to these people like
they're listening and hopefully they
will they hear me they hear you they
hear definitely yeah right hopefully
Glenn will come watch the show
um Glenn listen if you're gonna imitate
Tucker cart let me show you how to do
this why would he be why would he be
refused to go on mainstream media and
push the idea and the allocate it's just
an allegation are we scared of
allegations are we now somehow
inherently not strong enough to handle
allegations that might be true that both
is not a murderous dictator is that is
that something that we can't handle in
this country are we to believe that just
because Putin is his ally that he must
be our enemy too that's Glenn that is
how you do the Tucker Carlson you're
muted I don't know why but
I'm Beauty because my dog was barking
now oh okay oh yeah the point is is that
that that Glenn that is a Master Class
in how you do Tucker Carlson right I'm
just as long as you end the function I'm
just asking questions that's all I'm
doing
is that what we're supposed to believe I
mean again it's all bone-headed
and really people who are simple-minded
and and are ignorant of facts and
ignorant of how actual things work
um are easily duped by Tucker Carlson
not by Glenn Greenwald here he's really
shitty in it I mean even you know even
Tucker and his own legal team was like
you don't you you you you you cannot
watch this program and reasonably think
all right that what I'm telling you is
truth and then everyone's like oh I eat
that up it's the truth right well
let's finish how Glenn just totally
botches his Tucker impersonation here
let's let's continue Congress Massey
said on top of saying look regime chain
doesn't work he also doubted to the
great Rage of the CNN anchor the claim
that Assad use chemical weapons on his
own people Massey's argument was the U.S
government has said we will intervene in
Syria and change your government
under only one circumstance if you use
chemical weapons why so Congress Massey
would it make sense for Assad to then go
and do exactly that which the US
government has said would be the one
thing he had to do necessary
for
the US to get involved in that regime
change War namely get your out of
your mouth okay so here's the thing
here's the thing is um Thomas Massey
he's talking about Thomas Massey doing
Tucker Carlson better than he's doing on
CNN in 2017 because I almost bet if we
went and launched the stupid
clip of Thomas Massey spreading around
these lies that the government
was wrong when Assad was using
chemical weapons and and remember this
this is this is six-year-old
news and the reason why Glenn Greenwald
is even bringing this up in the first
place because it's in Putin's interest
to for for boneheads here to
question rather Assad and Putin or
murder his dictators they're not that's
all lies coming from coming from the
deep state cabal that is what he's
spinning here and he's trying to give
historical quote-unquote
examples of Lies the reason why and I
bet if we pull the clip from 2017 a
Massey talking to a CNN
anchor the scene anchor probably says
that's false that has been
proven false that's all just
because you read it in New York or
doesn't make it true Thomas
don't you not believe mainstream media
when you read it are only when it
fits your bias but here's the
thing Thomas Massey does the Tucker
Carlson thing better than Glenn
Greenwald and green Glenn Glenn admits
it here he's like what what why am I
supposed to believe that all Assad would
use the one thing that would cause the
federal government to intervene am I
supposed to believe that am I supposed
to be dumb enough to believe that Assad
that is that ridiculous and dumb that's
what he's doing it's what he's doing and
again the only reason why I bring this
clip up and a lot of people are going to
think that this clip is not relevant it
is a hundred percent relevant they are
they I don't know if I'm if I mean clear
enough they are laying out a strategy
for 2024 is what they're doing and this
is part of the strategy to make it
normalized holy we are already past
two hours I need to realize
Jesus Christ
folks we need three hours badly
um because I I didn't even get to this
Daniel Goldman clip please go watch this
clip maybe I'll do a special rant um and
I talked about this Goldman clip uh over
the weekend on Sunday but I really
wanted to talk about it today more in
length
um but maybe I'll do it on patreon or
something we're just running on time
Jesus Christ
oh he just there's just not enough
time there's just not enough time you
know we've talked about this before we
could stream for 12 hours a day
and still not get to everything yeah
like well it's not hit every single
point and mock them where they could be
mocked at every single turn and we still
wouldn't it would work wouldn't work
Amanda says three hours three hours all
day all day wow 12 hours seven days a
week we'd have to I feel like we'd
have to do shifts because
no no no I could I could I mean I I
would totally they would hate my guts
yeah but I could totally sit and do
eight twelve I mean eight twelve hours a
day is there any doubt I mean you've
talked to me on the phone even about
yeah yeah I know it's not that we I mean
we've done you talk for 12 hours a day
we've done we've done shows for six
hours we did the marching green that was
eight hours I think totally is that the
longest we've ever I think the Margie
Taylor green Georgia trial was the
longest the eight hours is what we had
yeah that was a that was a
you know there's a part of me that's
like I'd like to go outside and like
maybe see the sun you know and like
enjoy or vitamin D yeah you know or be
able to can your balls a bit You Know
sketch or do it what was that or see my
significant other whatever tell
everybody tell everybody that what was
that what's going on before we leave
because we're remembering so uh here
actually I made a little thing for it
huh did you did you do here you didn't
load in yeah
[Music]
oh that's beautiful there you go that's
a little thing we'll play it you know as
the show goes but yeah so are you gonna
make one for mine or I gotta make mine
I'll make one for you no no no no no
that's okay
I'll get one made up all right all right
but for people I've already got an idea
all right okay okay for people who don't
know I have a show called what was that
and it's a it's a as a segment that I do
on uh things that are happening you know
really in those those current events and
those news moments and make you do a
double take and you ask wait what was
that and that's what the show is you
know it's calling out and breaking down
somewhat complex issues and ones that
are like oh my God the world is so
on fire right now but allowing
to provide a laugh while giving you
digestible you know content at the same
time so I've got a show that's what it
is some of you have seen it uh I I show
it on on Midas Touch but I have a
patreon now
so I'll be doing behind the scenes I'll
be doing new content bonus clips that
are outside the studio as well as giving
you an exclusive access to to the
episodes before they go live
um so there's like a whole voting on
topics on what you think I should look
into or I have a topic or a a a group of
topics that I would like to get your
input on and what I should be doing the
next episode on so you know we're going
into episode 31 this week
um and so yeah you know go to patreon
patreon.com I am Gabe Sanchez or you can
go to what was that show.com that'll
redirect you to the patreon I've got a
link tree as well uh any support
um but yeah I got some exciting things
planned and talk about it more during
the week as well you know we should have
a competition going of uh how many
members we could have on our oh yeah I'm
just saying I mean I kind of got a head
start but I'm sure yeah you got a video
okay
whatever I'm just starting off you know
all right well hey hey everyone go
support Gabe um go to his link tree and
go to what was that show.com did I give
you what was that show.com right what
was that show.com and it'll redirect you
to the patreon take a look at it uh and
and and see if if I'm telling you the
content is worth support it's definitely
worth support
um if you have the extra money to help
support it do that if you but otherwise
watch it consume it share it
um it is a great piece of content and I
I I'm happy that Gabe has a piece of
content that I think he could grow to
five days a week
um and he could do one every single day
that's what I want him to do is go do
this every single day like like we do
right here on the Tony Michaels podcast
two hours or two hours and ten minutes
um on Mondays apparently uh I didn't
even I wasn't even watch on the clock
which is right
I was I was I was like oh yeah we'll
keep talking about Glenn greenwaldman
and his Brown
Gabe could tell that I was not winding
down because usually I got this little
the audience can tell too that I've got
this wine down that I do so yeah yeah um
so everyone make sure same time same
place tomorrow but please go check out
what was that show.com what was that
show.com it looks like I had to make it
there was a and there was a a redirect
well there was a redirect issue yeah uh
hold on let me see so go to patreon.com
I am Gabe Sanchez yeah yeah
patreon.com or or just go to
um Gabe's Twitter at I am Gabe Sanchez
you can follow the links there don't
forget to subscribe to the Tony Michaels
podcast And subscribe to Gabe's Channel
but the Tony Michaels podcast you're
here today so you might as well
subscribe while you're here also
download every single episode on Apple
Spotify and Google don't miss a single
one also you can go to the upwire.com
the upwire.com new creators Channel over
on YouTube you can follow us there we
broadcast from there live and when I've
been putting some shorts over there and
some other creators put videos over
there so go go follow that go follow
that same time same place tomorrow where
over time Surf's Up you've
been listening to the Tony Michaels
podcast in your face commentary of
current events and political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
them
[Music]
Murphy's mealborn head ass Beacon